[Música]
hablamos ahora de revista de prensa con
rosa pérez de hoy viernes de rosa
bienvenida muy buena mañana vamos
entonces a continuar con lo que ha sido
el seguimiento del asesinato de la
periodista al yazira sirena abu al ángel
en cisjordania presuntamente por parte
de las fuerzas israelíes mientras
trabajaba a las afueras de jenín en
cisjordania hoy el mirón y spain publica
el relato de una de sus periodistas que
fue testigo de los hechos y que todo el
mundo la pudo ver en un vídeo también en
redes sociales y agencias de noticias
que estaba al lado del cuerpo de la
periodista asesinada exactamente buenos
días raúl como decías es un relato en
primera persona por parte de sas a anaya
pero ella digamos que lo explicó de voz
a sus compañeras salsa ahmad y justicia
fayad pero como decíamos el relato está
en primera persona y va desde la mañana
cuando ella se levanta hasta que
fatídicamente tienen lugar el asesinato
de schilling pero empezamos ella dice
que alas sobre las 6 de la mañana le
llamó un periodista de the list
por si iba a cubrir la redada del
ejército israelí precisamente en el
campo de refugiados de jenín ella dice
que salió de su casa normalmente y que
llegó a una redonda antes del acceso a
este campo de refugiados dice ahí me
puse el casco de prensa y el chaleco
antibalas igual que los demás
periodistas que estaban conmigo pero
dice esa mañana en jenín era pues un día
más en que la gente iba a pie o en carro
hacia el trabajo y que incluso un
transeúnte que venía del campo de
refugiados les dijo no hay nada que
temer ahí dentro no pasa nada está todo
tranquilo y dijo dice que antes de
avanzar hacia el campo precisamente se
detuvieron para esperar a los
periodistas de al yazira entre los
cuales se orinaba a clegg y ella cuenta
como con la llegada no de ésta pues
mítica periodista de al yazira ella pues
se sintió un aura especial a pesar de
que no era la primera vez que se
encontraban dice ahí estaba la
periodista con su equipo a la que yo
crecí imitando no y por la que me quise
hacer un poco pues reportera dice que
bueno una vez todo el equipo ya de
periodista juntos se hicieron visibles
ante el ejército israelí para que se
dieran cuenta de que estaban ahí como
prensa y que no estaban armados y sólo
tenían como objetivo ir a cubrir la
redada clara rosa entonces contando esto
ya cómo empezó el ataque a los
periodistas pues ella dice que no había
disparos y que en ese momento empezaron
todos a andar no hacia la entrada del
campo de refugiados pero dice de la nada
escuchamos el primer disparo me di media
media vuelta y vi a mi colega al y al
samu di en el suelo una bala lo alcanzó
en la espalda pero como la herida no fue
de gravedad logró escapar y alejarse no
de la escena donde le habían alcanzado
precisamente otro periodista muyahid
logró saltar una pequeña valla y ponerse
también a resguardo y muy ahí les decía
a ella ya shirín que cruzaran para
ponerse también a resguardo pero que en
medio de los disparos que ya atribuye al
ejército israelí no podían arriesgarse a
cruzar la calle no la calle que se ve en
ese vídeo y que en ese momento escuchó
como shirín la periodista de al yazira
dijo al samu di ha sido atacado y dice
justo en ese momento otra bala atravesó
el cuello de jilín y cayó al suelo junto
a mí dice la llamé y no respondió y aquí
ya las imágenes que han dado la vuelta
al mundo no dice cuando trataba de
extender mi van mi mano para alcanzarla
salía disparada otra bala y tuve que
quedarme detrás del árbol dice ese árbol
salvó mi vida y dice que cada vez que
intentaba tomar el pulso de shiring sus
compañeros y decían que se quedará atrás
y dijo de la nada una residente del
campo de refugiados logró llegar ahí con
un automóvil que por una carretera fuera
del alcance del ejército israelí y
llevarles hasta al hospital que dice
ella entonces rosa acerca de la autoría
del asesinato que dice la periodista que
de la que estamos hablando que cuenta
toda esa historia pues dice que lo que
pasó fue un intento deliberado de
matarnos y quien disparó tenía como
objetivo matar y fue un francotirador
israelí dice no estábamos atrapados en
el fuego cruzado como afirmó el ejército
israelí no hubo enfrentamientos en ese
momento dice también la periodista hace
tiempo que ya se prepara para morir
porque dice israel no diferencia entre
mayores y menores hombres son mujeres
civiles periodistas o combatientes todo
el mundo es un objetivo finalmente
también explica lo difícil que fue para
ella reportar documentar los momentos en
el hospital y a más tarde en el funeral
y termina este relato de la siguiente
manera alrededor del cuerpo estábamos
musulmanes y cristianos escuchando las
palabras del sacerdote en silencio
cuando miré a mi alrededor vi muchas
cámaras filmando detrás de cada una
había un periodista palestino sollozando
sabiendo que shirín nunca más estaría al
otro lado de esos lentes como
periodistas palestinos nuestra pérdida
es indescriptible pero más que nunca
nuestro trabajo es importante para
documentar las violaciones de la
ocupación por nuestros valores
periodísticos por la verdad y porque
precisamente hoy rosa se celebra el
entierro de la periodista avale en
jerusalén que esta calle gira pues que
desde el año 2000 45 periodistas han
sido asesinados a manos de las fuerzas
israel y cita al director de human right
watch para israelí-palestina omar sakhir
que dice la realidad es que no hay
rendición de cuentas por este tipo de
abusos cuando se trata de acciones de
las autoridades israelís gracias.rosa
por toda la información nos vemos el
lunes con más revista de prensa que en
directo américa pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día